going back to wordplay do you
think that you could duplicate that
success again theatrically
and what do you see in the next five
years it just seems like tougher and
tougher now that
everyone's you know filmmaking is pretty
much open to everybody
yeah uh it there's that many more
eyeballs you know yeah being taken away
from
stuff is is this
something that's easily and i'm
stumbling for words here but
could you duplicate it again um yeah i
mean wordplay was
very special you know we we went off to
sundance
that year hopefuls and we came out
filmmakers with a with a really
successful film
um very sick i mean it did very well
um it was in the within the top
25 um highest box office of all time
for for documentaries got great reviews
we won a little golden tomato from
rotten tomatoes we were the best review
documentary of the year
i mean it was like kind of everything
kind of went right with that film
um and you know the thing is that was
god that was almost 10 years ago and the
landscape has changed
dramatically but that said i i think
that i think that anyone could do this
again
um i mean the the key
i think the key changes that have
happened
in the at least in the documentary
landscape but i think this is also true
of narratives
um a lot more people are making films
but it's still pretty hard to make a
really good film
it just because there's a lot of cameras
in the world doesn't mean there's going
to be a lot of great movies in the world
i mean
i think i think there is more great work
being done
but the the obstacles
you know that stand before a filmmaker
who's hoping to make a really really
good film
are still really high it's hard to do
that it's hard to
it's hard to accomplish that
so you know i think if if we really
wanted to make a movie
that could sell for a lot of money
and find a really really big audience
i think we could do that again i i don't
it's not impossible
um that's also not necessarily
what we're aiming for um with our work
i mean if we're getting paid to make our
films
and we make a great film um
that's way more important to us than a
big splashy sale
at sundance or somewhere else i mean
truly in fact
the reason we made it if you build it
which is a
fairly small story in a small town in
north carolina no one in the movie is is
well known or famous
we knew going in like this is not going
to be word play this is not going to be
io usa which which was a nonpartisan
look at the national debt
that had people like warren buffett was
in the film several
treasury secretaries several chairmen of
the federal reserve i mean there were
like a lot of kind of famous people in
that movie as well
and this was different and it was like a
different mountain for us to climb
which is which is part of the reason we
did it
but yeah i mean we're working on a
project now it's too early to really
talk about it yet but i mean we're
working on a project now that i think
could have a much bigger audience than
wordplay so
we'll see that's probably two years away
so we'll
we'll see if we'll see if we get there
you